hello happy Monday we are technically an
hour and a half fish almost later than
normal audience might live but that's
because we were waiting for a new game
apex legends from respawn entertainment
of new battle royale that Rob's already
seen a new contender we're actually
still downloading coz for every reason
it keeps cutting in and out for us but
because everyone in the world is trying
to download it right now there's a
couple cool things we we have gameplay
from the preview event that you saw it
at where you and I think Phil horn Shaw
got to see it so did you want to pull
that up while we wait for sure yeah
we're good you're good all right so you
asked some questions
know if we have chat oh yeah I got you
chat yes you're good dude let's ask
questions and I can help answer them I
got a game play yeah I'll do it don't
worry you you worry about yours what
just happened
chat there we go so as you can see here
you pick you pick your legend legend
mm-hmm character excuse me I just
inhaled a sandwich I'm good
he's good so three people on a team it's
it's it's what's different about this
battle royale is that I would say that
it's very tactical in squad base I know
there are like squad modes and different
battle battle Royales but here who was
like really ham-fisted because you have
all these cool ways of pinging and
communicating with your team you really
do stick together like the game does a
great job about that but as you can see
there in the beginning you pick a
character so it's got like essentially
like overwatch is a good comparison hero
based or legends characters that you
pick you can only pick one you can't
pick all the same legend so each team
has to have three different types so you
could you know you could think about as
you're picking you want to like someone
who won't would want to be a support
class which is kind of the character I'm
playing which is lifeline which is like
your medic she has like a heal drone
she's got a care package that could
essentially drop good loot
other people on team either the top guy
there that you've seen with the goggles
his name is what yes thank you he has he
can like scan it everything operates on
a cool down your tactical ability so you
can see I you know people in the area
and then Wraith is the other one she can
use the phase shift if you remember
titanfall 2 she can kind of warp out
into the void sneak around and then
spawn back in it's on all platforms
someone asking that I'm we are currently
downloading PC but because of what
happened with anthem I also have a ps4
here downloading it as well that one
seemed more stable it's just not going
as fast as the PC was the PC one was
fluctuating a lot it would go to like 0%
and then like we'd pause it and come
back we're like almost halfway done
installing it technically we've
downloaded enough of it to play it but I
don't know exactly what that means if
it's just like the tutorial or something
like that but what you're seeing here is
not actually us playing yet it's a
gameplay that we or Rob and Phil
recorded do you know which one this was
this is putting me this is me playing
yeah I was I'm going to turn up a little
bit but I know you guys have something
Mike like you guys talk throughout this
right a little bit oh yeah that's that's
good okay so did you talk about the
other difference slightly that like you
you have like well I guess you see it
later maybe the respawning yeah so
something that this game does
differently among a lot of things I
would say is that one of the more
notable ones is that yes you have the
you know on your team you can go down
and your teammate can revive you so you
kind of are in a crouched state but you
can die permanently as long as someone
one person on your team is alive that
person can go to your dead body and pull
your banner and go to a respawn station
and you get to come back in on an
airship and then you're back in the game
so there's a sense of like longevity I
want to say like it even like arguably
time-to-kill takes a long time so your
it feels that compared to other battle
Royales like there are reasons to like
actually keep watching and spectating
because again you're kind of rooting for
you're really running for your team in
essence and
again there's a lot of cool that this
pinging system so you can see here that
little there so he painted this and he
said hey there's a there's a heavy mag
here for your heavy weapon that's just
by using like I guess on the mouse it's
like the so that right there example I
just like hit my weapon I said I need
more ammo for this plan everything's
very intuitive and it's like you know if
you're playing a game you don't have a
mic or someone on your team doesn't have
like you can get by like pretty well you
can get you cannot get a Titan no that's
how you never know wall running yeah so
yeah we'll check our download in a
little bit I'm guessing we're not that
close yet but we appreciate everyone
tuning in if you have questions please
throw them into the chat Rob to get to
see and play the game already we
probably also have impressions going up
as well but stay with us we will be in
the game hopefully shortly I'm also
curious to see how the stability is now
that it's kind of out in the world it's
a free to play as well so you know you
can get in there try it out some lot of
people asking if you need PS plus I
believe you do but I wanna double check
our PlayStation download to actually see
if you need it yes I could so these are
all the same weapons from tie-in ville -
just with different skins cuz I'll you
know this game is free-to-play so you're
you could say the progression is all
tied into Cosmetics just for both you
and your weapons
ya know double jumping unfortunately no
wall running when we asked the
developers that they kind of they kind
of well they responded by saying that
like when they tried doing that
adding wall running and test phases it
was just too messy like people were
flying all over the map and also I think
you brought up the point to that like
teammates were getting separated yeah
things like that just because people are
like it's hard it's it's far harder to
like follow a teammate when your wall
running because it's like so chased
a speed induced like function of the
game so yeah if you can see there's like
there's like X's mmm red x's on some of
the item in gear and that's pretty cool
like that lettuce flat out say what you
have of your two weapons what's
compatible like you have a scope but it
doesn't work for your two weapon so you
might as well ditch it yeah that's kind
of like that it's a accessibility this
is kind of different I don't know if for
tonight does this I feel like they do
but you can like see these balloons all
on the map and if you're you know on the
outskirts of the map and you need to get
into the circle quick you can like use
those two to kind of fling yourself like
higher up so you can kind of get close
like right Traverse sorry that's poor
warding it's similar but it doesn't I
don't believe it's like here's a balloon
that you go up to it still sounds great
yeah yeah and like you said that time to
kill you could really a while LMG
headshots yeah yeah you've been your
teammates a nicely done okay so there's
some more questions coming in Rob let me
send those to you can you dance in this
game ask gavrok ins there's emotes but I
think they are just specific to you like
your banner so you kind of create like
your own profile and that's if you can
see the outskirts of the in-game there's
like big screens that kind of see oh
yeah you can kind of customize that you
can you know put some character there uh
Anthony to Rodriguez to how far it is a
slide go oh so that's the one thing I
will say is like wow there isn't wall
running they make the slide so opie so
like any Hill you can slide down and
like you can slide like forever it feels
like so people a lot of people use them
the slide that's kind of like you know
in a way a replacement wall running
that's interesting shield yeah so when
you're down you have the limit amount of
shield to kind of prolong your death and
Evon with death if you yeah so he's
shotgunning your team but luckily
I'm guessing you see there it goes right
there I'm turning it on nice
I'm fairly sure it's like has a set
amount it says 250 there yeah I think
you have if they hit it yeah that much
damage yeah yeah Adam all right yes it
is on ps4 also an Xbox let's see someone
says lol the titanfall without the fun
stuff I mean it is part of the this one
some of the fun aspects of the gamers
would say it's all of it
but the shooting is still like really
great in titanfall like that's still
something that later I'm sure a lot of
people gonna ask this when red lights
kind of bringing it up as well how did
so you played blackout obviously which
you know was more recent another more
recent Battle Royale
how does this kind of compare to that
how would I compare it to blackout I
mean again like I feel like if there's
things that blackout does not do well I
feel like their menu system and like how
you navigate and team chat like I think
it's kind of tedious I think it's harder
to get around here it's like so much
more simpler and so much more
approachable especially if you know the
weapons of titanfall too like I do like
I like it feels great because I know
exactly what I'm picking up granted
that's because I know titanfall but I
still find that all the menu in UI like
far more approachable and well done and
well thought so they're like the exes
again I'm not even gonna bother picking
up that that backpack because I already
have a higher level one that the game
will tell you like just say like it'll
be like you have a better scope there's
no need to pick this up so I think
that's that's like makes the game the
gameplay like far more important and
they're like kind of speeds that up in a
way but again like the smaller things as
fall as far as like there's just a lot
there's a lot it just feels like a lot
more to do I guess in it's a kind of
smaller map but the abilities is the one
kicker I would say is is what sets it
apart is is you know you have a
stability you have your ultimate and you
have your tactical ability so I have a
drone that can use as a medic here's a
care package I can don't like this might
have a high high level gear in it
that's your cool it's my alter yeah okay
the other thing too is that there is a
high level gear and you'll see me I have
it on actually I have a piece of armor
that's the legendary the highest level
gear you can get legendary gear has a
perk this perk is that I'm gonna have is
when I do a finisher and someone who's
down my shields get recharged and this
one I pick up I think it says no threat
this is a scope but it says close range
so it'll close rein op close range
objects or people excuse me we'll have a
threat indicator on it cool denne denne
d I believe at least at first glance it
looked like six gigs but I think that's
six kids to start playing and then I'm
not sure about the rest of it Jake snake
assuming he's not lying since 23 gigs
you can download it on PS the
PlayStation Store you can download it on
Origin if you're playing for PC and then
I'm guessing the Xbox store also has it
it's out now free to play
I still can't haven't got full
confirmation on if you if you need PS
plus or not it didn't say or state it so
I would say anyone that doesn't happy s
let's try it again we're not playing
currently because we're still
downloading one check your download
maybe you let me go full cam or
something while you do this and they go
full camp real quick and we're gonna see
how our down was doing we are it's still
fluctuating now you're good I think but
it's not doing what it means to you
anyways it's fine you can go back to it
I'm not sure about the PS plus
unfortunately I apologize let me go back
to the gameplay that we have apologies
that fully downloaded yet I'm sorry
downloading a ps4 as well I do have PS
plus so it's not the greatest example
but if we need to play that first we can
at least oh okay so I'm getting news
from Phil Horne Shaw apex definitely
doesn't include the PS plus requirement
that is listed on other games I just
checked it against the division so I
think no PS
plus is required but they're also gonna
check with the PR company as well just
to verify that so yeah so this is
something I'm on that's kind of cool it
like there are these like high high
level I'm sorry or these these
essentially these floating platforms or
ships that float around the map that you
can like start the match in the air and
land on and there's a bunch of
high-level loot on it so it's kind of
cool to like if you want it's you know
Oh higher risk reward to land on this
thing and battle or people who were
going for it as well right let's say you
do need PS plus and live gold so I guess
we'll need to double check that uh yeah
it's free from if you want it on PC it's
only on origin that is correct
yeah as mentioned as Roxanne says it's
an EA game so yeah you're getting the
origin was the game called apex legends
this is again recorded footage
that's why Rob's kind of like sifting
through it just looking for moments for
you guys our download was like at 60%
we are just struggling a little bit for
whatever reason so this is get it this
is what we're saying earlier like this
is your own banner that you can
customize so if you're doing well in
game people can see you nice I think a
couple other battle royale games do
something like that if you put your gun
away if you put your guns away and have
no just be your unarmed you can run
faster there's like kind of like neat
tricks to this game question for you
because you know there is gonna be I
mean the game itself is free brothers
monetization stuff right so how does
that play it does that affect gameplay
or is it cosmetic it doesn't affect
gameplay you can unlock any everything
in game obviously it just takes oh it'll
take some time if you were to do that
naturally in game but everything is
cosmetic so it's not any finding any
means of pay to win the only thing that
our locked are the two characters
there's eight there are two characters
that you will have to work towards so in
a way I feel like that's like the only
progression that you would have to like
kind of focus on so I guess I'm trying
to say is like you could get those two
characters immediately
or you could maybe spend like the 20
hours I would say to unlock them and
that's just by playing the game you get
rewards as you play whack ow l-- asking
is it a two gun loadout yeah two gun
with loadout yeah mmm Thank You Jake for
the info for the rest of chat and then
you can pick up like three different
types of grenades there's like flashbang
the gravity star kind of thing I have
really figured it out and then just like
a classic oh and then sorry there's like
maybe four types grenade and then like
thermite which i think is kind of just
the same it kind of it kind of does like
AOE okay Anthony's now saying for the PS
Plus thing we'll find out definitively
clearly I'm hearing mixed things so
sorry about that but it is in the store
I found it right away it was like the
first thing on the store I'll look at
this this silly person and I when I cook
times I could have pinged the guy with
the third mouse button and been like hey
there's someone here but I didn't in
words like I don't know because I suck
did you not have another garden to use I
don't have much ammo for I don't think I
spit fire the LMG sorry I totally just
do Robin to the bus there could you have
like there's no like one hit execute or
something like from behind right like if
you punched him or something no there's
melee oh yeah this is free agile films
is it good
Rob your takes I haven't played it yet
so I don't really like battle royale
games that much but if I were to play
one I'd probably play this that's how I
honestly feel
but I will preface it by saying Rob is a
huge titanfall fan as well which
obviously helps right because like you
said you have a more familiarity when
the weapons is the appeal even
aesthetically probably yeah so it's kind
of like how I felt about blackout when I
first came in I was like I know Cod I
don't want to build you know whoa
that is the gameplay yes anyways but I'm
interested in this one too I kind of
like the ability stuff and like you said
it it does feel like there's more
teamwork
oh so look so look at CC this
this legendary backpack but I'm playing
with the dev here because we played last
week
that's a legendary backpack it has a
fast he'll perk all legendary gear in
and I guess mods for weapons and yeah
healing time healing items take half as
long that's pretty cool it is available
now we could bet you can download it on
all three platforms yep as the Devas
saying can you hear him I have five
minutes or less on the ps4 download so
yeah go in a second give that over to
rob the only thing is you might have to
play off this monitor Rob so not the end
of the world obviously but yeah so we're
almost there so I'll fast forward it
then to like so you can also get perks
that you can pick up like for instance
one will like increase for a period of
time increase the rate your ultimate
comes back okay so those are things I
mean you know Call of Duty blackout kind
of has some of those this is definitely
not titanfall 3 mud pig I mean not only
are there no Titans but there's also no
wall running so I wouldn't say that I
mean the closest things like
relationship-wise from this game and
titanfall is that one it's made by
respawn 2 it has a you know similar what
weaponry right that's in the same
universe as Tydfil and then it has like
building aesthetics that are like the
same but I wouldn't say too much more
than that I guess can't get on Android
no shout-out to my cabbage there you go
shout-out to the cabbage I'm gonna check
the PS no it's been too soon it's too
soon I can't check it I gotta wait so
there isn't any wall running or jumping
or airtime stuff like that it's more
grounded but you have a crazier slide I
guess and I'm sure people are gonna
figure stuff out and do some crazy stuff
at some point I don't know I haven't
played it to be honest yeah there's a
well I definitely well it's something
I've
I would like to see down the road is
people getting really really like
creative with people's abilities because
there's one where it's like you can
essentially make portals like getting
out portals so you could like you could
see different ways of of using them it's
like succinct with other people on your
team I don't know that could be pretty
neat
Molotov shoutouts to you Molly and
Minnie
there you go boom cross-platform I don't
think so right no I don't think so no
yeah no yeah right I feel like again
that's like one of those things where
it's up to PlayStation and I think
PlayStation has opened up like what
cross-play like beta program so to speak
so rocket League has made made it on
that list we did that stream while ago
so so the opening is there but there's
no confirmed cross play mm-hmm but I
don't know I almost feel like it'll be
PS 5 and select games I don't know like
I did right here right here oh yeah
you're going though you're new you
dodged all those bullets yeah right yeah
now that Oh grenades you can't just
throw you have to equip them and then
throw if that makes sense it's kind of
if that's you you're the chick okay so
that's a windscreen that's what it looks
like you are the champion even though
like you shouldn't be like champions cuz
you're on a team together I don't know
maybe everyone else on your team is all
for tuning in guys and gals we really
appreciate it we're checking out Apex
legends is it ready oh it's done alright
let's get into it
boom didn't even need my ps4 version I
should just play on the side see look
it's loading up or whatever I'll just
show that screen because that's what you
guys want to see anyways I mean we
appreciate it
it is free to play as mentioned all
three major platforms I suppose ooh
allow that access PC ps4 Xbox one out
now go play
if you want if not I would say plate and
have our stream open at the same time
because you know why not
right and you do what is going on here
oh they go do we want to play I want to
play this I guess
got newspaper so you think you've got
what it takes
they call us a makes legends
but not all legends by heroes okay
each fighter
from the ashes of war legends are born
there are cones our strength power
outside the ring they're champions
inside they're equals
but the gull remains the same we become
an apex legend
I say it's a sport of survival
you ask me it's simple hi
they kill you
they're better
you kill them
you're better okay
another minor gripe right now Rob which
if you're trying to become an apex
legend right and you win the game should
you be
you are the legend not you are the
champion I don't know it's so it's such
a small stupid point that I just you
must get good I wish he said you must
get good ooh
origin access thousand oh we got
currencies so much currency oh look at
all these guns that are like locked away
[Music]
can you unlock them wrong okay so those
are the two you're talking about right
yeah I can unlock one right now who do
you like more caustic or mood eyes
Holley Mirage I'm me - you want to look
at the store real quick you want to get
that out of the way all right
this is what the store looks like I'm
sure someone's gonna ask later so
there's a bunch of ways right there's
this there's like currencies are two so
I could buy two three of these let's
just not do that right now
okay there's a the one other legend
currently there might be more on the way
here are your coins if you ever were to
buy them anyways why just play rob yep
let's get into it we have two friends in
the apex oh I have to play training
alright get ready to Train sorry guys we
gotta go through training
I mean to become a legend you do you do
have to train as appose can we stop with
the hero specialist stuff already
no it's like the new iteration I guess
of multiplayer shooters it used to be
that you could just you know have a
slide some good old-fashioned shooting
but now we have abilities because but I
do I do say I want to say though I do
like that there is a that there is the
differentiation of classes because I
feel like some people like to play
certain classes more than others and so
having like a support class is cool you
know obviously I think they'll probably
evolve and have more legends down the
road so hopefully there's enough legends
come come down the road to to kind of
create that variant of gameplay
let's choose a tokens got a point if
you're not if you're not a fan and
you're just in here to crap talk you
might as well just get out of here
because obviously you're just in here to
talk the smack when why we're here to
check out a new game and you know chat
about it again as mentioned earlier Rob
wented the preview event to saw this
game earlier last last week's it is kind
of a minor shame in my mind that a lot
of stuff leaked but you know it's how it
goes I guess instead we get everyone
gets to enjoy this game now ooh I like
it sounds good
it's a pity there's no wall running yeah
as Rob mentioned earlier in talking and
speaking to the devs they said it just
kind of made things way Messier right
yeah they wanted to focus more on like
the tactical abilities and sticking with
your team and every time they like added
wall running people were like flying all
over the place and it was like harder to
follow where your team was because
that's what they'd rather put my time
into it about Royale and maybe maybe you
could say the same about titans maybe
that was a similar thing we're like it
just made things too complicated for a
battle royale game which is what they
wanted to do for like first and foremost
okay so here's a cool thing this is the
paying system where it's like I'm
pinging cool stuff here so I can ping
ammo here so if I go hey I need more
ammo I'm looking for an optic DoubleTap
noob we haven't even put out a review so
know that question is silly
I think the review will come out later
this week I think Phil I believe it's
just out Dogu got doe [ __ ] on
free-to-play on multiple platforms
hi friend I'm Pathfinder
there's nothing solo right it's always
squad-based
always quad yeah so there's a kind of
semi answer to that video but don't
worry with skill everyone can have the
chance to be revived just approach your
dummy and hold the prompt button on your
HUD to revive them are you okay can't
find it on the piste or after he's
starting I know it's not finding it
really I want to get the other thing you
could try doing is searching for it I
believe I found it by searching apex
legends as well you still have a chance
to bring your friend back approach dummy
stash and grab their banner great you
can use that banner to bring back your
friend through any active respawn beacon
approach the respawn beacon and when
prompted hold for activation I would try
to confirm file sizes a couple people
have said 20 like 22 23 gigs on P so it
was it was yeah 23 or 22 was like 22 or
23 yeah okay and then some people are
saying 17 gigs on ps4 and then now we'll
let's place as 25 26 on Xbox so in that
range roughly
there's no fall damage I thought that
wasn't you saying yeah Anthony brings up
another good point if you can't find out
the PS Store search we're on PlayStation
comm that also works well I see a
dinosaur yeah those are those monsters
from my first time falling on I would
like to put our supply drop down I'm
trying to here's your Tydfil
it looks a lot like a mod you can ask
that in a nicer way and I can probably
do that here's a just did that because
heavy metal jelly at says guys are there
any air drops especially are there other
air drops just throughout the map oh
that's a good question I wanted to say
like no I don't think so they're my pee
but I don't think so like there's no
other character that does that what I
just did
all right we finished training we're
official
yeah Austin Baird also confirming 17
gigs on ps4 yeah thank you to all the
folks just telling the other folks in
chat how to find it on ps4 store
appreciate you guys all being mostly
civilized and helping each other out
it's a great to see someone says what
happens when a dead teammate leaves the
game then that's it and they don't get
back in so it's may be ill-advised to
leave so early
oh so now all this stuff opens up and we
see you know skins and stuff I don't
know I before in our impressions like
this stuff doesn't do much for me but I
mean it looks cool I guess I just don't
really I'm guessing you earn like loot
boxes do you earn them yeah that's so
you can get them and then you can get
loot boxes for playing a game then you
can use money here like 100 100
apex coins let's play let's do it who
you're gonna are you playing this Mirage
or so you pick when you fire up a game
but you can like you know how someone to
look at while you're waiting let's see
here I will probably go with sure I'll
use barrage contagious so here no you
could get a thousand for ten I mean I
got a thousand drop the bags it's free
I'll use this skin cool looks nice
for all those asking how to find out on
ps4 check the ps4 store someone else
said check the free section can also
search for it I believe how many players
on the map it's a 60 right so 60 20
squad 20 teams squads of three all right
here we go oh man oh we're gonna have to
do muting Oh fine
yeah well let's play yeah yeah loot box
is interesting it's cosmetic though
right so yeah alright I mean as much as
I know people hate loot boxes I've never
had a problem with them as long as
they're cosmetic I just don't like it
when it affects the game itself or gives
an advantage of some so what's
interesting is either your third to pick
a character you get to choose where to
drop so this person has shields and his
ultimate is like an artillery strike she
can do the jump out of into the void a
phase shift so shouldn't kind of go into
different realm then come back and then
her ultimate is set up portals to do
this rub Kat consoles and PC JP but for
PC you're going to need to have origin
there's already a champion squad
it looks like tine fault well there are
definitely there are definitely some
assets I would say it's not pay to win
so we're just pay to its pay to look
good is how I look at it it's looking
you can easily see our teams this team
here it's kind of close otherwise that
team what do you think is gonna be like
the Tilted tower or tilt it yet is that
where a lot of people go it used to be
so that right there oh you can go on
that and if you land on it there's a
bunch of good loot so that's like a hot
zone can people know that I don't know
we should have went there nearby a group
there let's let's dance
his apex cosplay I don't believe so cool
good to see mantling is it only 60
players I believe so yeah did they talk
about plans of like any like variance or
things down the road like changing of
the map or it's like certain modes or
not a whole lot there they have not said
what they're gonna do post release but
they do Stu have said that they're
definitely gonna be and like you know
having more stuff so I just spotted them
cookies I don't think you're gonna hit
with that
nice okay using that whole team coming
and pushing there's a whole team yep
that's a horrible drop anyway
oh did you guys lose this alright the
last guy I should have waited
I don't know you're good I could have
waited to see if like are we would have
survived but didn't look like it
leveling seems pretty fast no I got a
pack here
definitely not super gory sorry we're
just kind of I can just do it all here
right mark where to party act if you
think it depends on which platform
you're on but what the party for us is
PC well so far this is great because
when I played there were only 60 people
at the event so it was hard to get into
a match but I'm right back in it so
that's nice
getting warmed up first game didn't use
any my abilities in a lot of scenario
yeah he's a grapple
oh he has a grapple yeah oh well there's
his ultimate can set like a zipline
Optimus Prime wants to know can you
slide hop in this game no I don't think
so
I don't know I haven't really tried to
do that one with two people
Oh triple Rex playing huh that's a
destiny player oh yeah yeah yeah do it
alright so Rob says if you drop on that
ship you're gonna get the good the good
good we're going to try it so
it really doesn't like or is it more
like oh no someone's there ooh gold arm
right you were not wrong Rob come on
decoy oh you can still decoy while
you're dead oh cool your teammate oh
okay that's just gotta be that's got to
be a visual bugger no that's so lame
all right no fall damage Oh still good
hold that what I feel bad for the one
guy on top hey dude get off
I still have legendary armor so I didn't
get that
you charged it up dude that we can't
help her there's no way like fell
through the world was there
I just don't have anything good oh great
finisher what oh yeah all right okay you
get a research recharge oh maybe partner
I have that okay you could be that you
could be the hero Rob yeah both up
although that the other person might be
like way far away okay so you're out of
ammo huh oh they're so far away I think
they're on the ship is why yeah but I
came and get her banner anyways thank
you guys again for tuning in
hit us up with questions if you got Rob
is looking currently for ammo it looks
like this place might have been looted
he didn't run into a team of three
earlier and it looks like your other
team at the the robot guy left
it's something we kind of noticed like
it is mo was really hard to come by I'm
just gonna friggin leave can you tried
the slide hop I don't even know like do
you have a job yeah but like I don't
know I don't see it being a value I
don't know how that would work cuz you
slide like you're grounded like slide
and jump and then do that and then shoot
and then shoot that's what I would think
I guess
so maybe Optimus Prime is that is that
kind of like what you're talking about
sorry I didn't really he's talking about
I know he's talking about he's talking
about a dude he's talking about one yeah
I was he's talking Mayan time well two
were like you can you can like retain
speed by like doing that the like it
doesn't really work here I feel like
there is nothing there's nothing dude
you're gonna go back to who was that a
legendary he's baiting you
no just kidding you might be actually
there's a box down there maybe that's a
person showing that melee that yeah
chibs done that earlier well I just left
or melee
just left that's all right hey you
weren't wrong though about that ship I
know right that's the good that's got
some legendaries in that for sure yeah
so I got crafting parts no while running
or double jumping Devon
welcome to prime says it seems like you
slow down when you jump yeah doesn't
does it retain that momentum yeah that
carry the momentum yeah and I get to
pick where to jump tree going that uh
that floating craft again it's up to you
if you can convince your teammates to do
it that was a weird thing for you to
like fall through which is yeah that's
been like off the revive or something
yeah oh definitely was for sure didn't
it didn't like put me on there oh you
get to choose where you're going right
so yeah I'm pretty sure all right so
you're gonna play support okay so
there's two support classes cool to kind
of like the fender and yeah what do you
what do they classify bloodhound does I
don't know recon like recon scout okay
no actually I forget now it was like I
think it was like specialist recon
special interesting all right
so you can customize what that will show
banners yeah I like your your you could
you could pick your Katy you could say
we're going for the ship and as Rob as
mentioned if you guys didn't know
there's like kind of higher-end loot on
that ship but obviously I think other
people are starting to figure that out
or know about it because we ran into
another team how's the optimization on
PC Rob feels good as from Umbra Terrence
Smith this is so this is black out for
free basically
ah not necessarily but I mean like if
you want to draw this from here since
you can but I won't go there optics
is it purple there
all right your teammates dead dead
that's a person for the hill get down
here
oh she's falling oh there's a guy named
Tay on your team I know sorry
that's awesome he's doing work to pay
one five one three do guns have much
recoil I think we got him
yeah there's recoil on these things
he's puppy puppies you might have it
equipped actually you have a you have a
cold optics on your thing Latoya Oh to
the ship land yeah it lands in the end
Twitter oh that kind of cool devotion we
should go ping a spot Rob you got a
penis spot ooh there's ammo down there
level one
oh yeah well like take your items
got to be faster up I know I've got to
do that typical battle royale shimmy no
Jason you cannot are you guys I'm
guessing you guys are in the circle
right
the only thing that is a little bit
unfortunate I guess but it makes sense
is that you know if you're if you're if
you can't recover a banner to revive a
teammate it's just unfortunate that you
know I'm gonna guess that most people
are not going to wait it out unless like
you know what I mean
yeah I I wouldn't even because you just
want to play another game unless you
were with your buddy unless you're
playing with actual friends I could see
you hanging in there but there are the
grandeur there are stations like Pollard
place respawn stations there so fire
going on there and fire no it's on
origin it's an EA game because it's made
by Respawn Entertainment is this that in
the titanfall universe yeah apparently
30 years after titanfall to hexagon has
had much downloading on ps4 as I watch
thank you for watching while downloading
appreciate it who is your favorite
legend so far as Zach Davis
I like lifeline the medic who you're
playing Kurt yeah currently I'm just cuz
it's like II it's easy for me to get and
I have to worry about how to use my
abilities because it's no automatically
how to use them you know I mean it's
just like oh I remember is like to use
my drone once in a while to help heal
people and situations and then I have an
ultimate that I do like trauma Sakina
system though I love it yes definitely
helps yeah use that oh no wait there's
another one in front of you to your
right I don't believe this cross play
[Music]
not sure that will change but but it is
on all three of the major platforms if
you wanna try it it's for you to play
just go down low
Jason I would say yeah I mean it is a
little bit unfortunate that you know if
you really want to wall run with it
there isn't wall run but I would say try
it out like it's free you never know you
might end up liking it you might not but
it doesn't there's definitely no harm in
trying because if you enjoy titanfall
you know like Rob did I think this kind
of scratches some of those one say the
exact same inches but you know what I
mean like it gives you something I
didn't need it because I didn't work
with anything I had but you don't know
if your marks excited to jump on 13
minutes ago oh how much does the does
the zone hurt like oh I don't know I've
actually never tested that okay Eva
wasn't your favorite right I'm gonna
take it they do come in Rob hmm I don't
know if it's because another lifeline
made it when I've dropped it or not what
did you say what came in care package or
something oh it's a purple behind you no
idea if you need it no oh he took it all
right well I'm gonna drop this
let's explore this way incoming care
package what do we got a lot
[ __ ] at least tell him to take that
right yeah is this coming console it is
on console it's already there go
download it I scared me there are no
respawn game-mode guys only elimination
you can respawn or well it's not respawn
you can revive and then you can also get
your teammates banners and then take it
to a respawn location and then bring
them back but there's not currently in
the game like a mode that has respawn
yeah I agree just good you have one kill
I'm not sure how many days got but
okay so you even see the banners indoors
like alright that guy is the number
number one or that squads like the
number one squad I think it's cool it's
cold system no I like it I like it I
definitely do too it's just it's just
funny that you're using the box as the
indicator like yeah I'm pretty sure
someone's okay I definitely didn't open
that mom I'm just you know free-to-play
yes keep him keeping my guy on my toe on
his toes you know a lot of the areas are
definitely open fire it's out on ps4 as
well extreme it's on the store extendo
mag hmm for it four by eight X this is
good
that'll recharge my shield like a lot I
need some better yeah better armor piece
max ammo no I'm just
I'm not sure if it's Xbox 1x enhanced
Okemah reloaded sorry about that there's
so much Safari and squad left oh they
were on the ship huh no or they yeah
they went up there oh gosh yeah that's
smart that's how you get kind of like
verticality come back down Traverse yeah
those balloons kind of all over like
that's what's that's what's neat is it
like there's always something you can be
doing in the game you know what I mean I
don't know like I like oh it's I could
be wrong but it just feels like there's
so many things to think about like
that's why I kind of find this
interesting as far as like a battle
royale like it makes me think a little
differently
I mean I could maybe swap it for like
now where should we go we'll go this way
you guys are in a good spot on the
outskirts of the thing is there bullet
drop and our guns hit scan it's on
origin orphan Orhan sorry it is out on
PC burnt toasts I don't PC ps4 and Xbox
one that whole team went over here wow
this is we have a 4 4 X 8 what's the
price it's free
oh yeah
nice ping extreme exam B it's a 60
players per match so that's 20 squads of
three it's only squads no solos at least
as of yet also because there are classes
in this game so it kind of makes sense
so far that there isn't playing tactical
here at 2:04 and swap I'm more of a two
to four X kind of yeah I'm pretty bad
with the super long range stuff yeah but
you basically have a long range and
short and that's it yeah fine you ain't
a was it one five one three can you not
fill your squat well once the match
starts we lost one of our teammates
early and then we couldn't recover their
banner because I think they were like up
top
and so now they just left the game and
we're finishing it the rest of the game
there's seven squads left so like 16
people left is what the Oh in that I'm
blocking the top right my fault y'all I
can move us middle right but I don't
know if that's maybe let me show you
that guy's right middle is good yeah I'm
gonna go right middle oh I think whoa
god [ __ ] dude get here
is he not like crawling over to you oh
there's two guys they're almost robbed F
Oh what's up yellow Sanchez left mid you
guys all want left mid all right we love
it I'll fix it while Rob gets back into
another match did you guys get pinched
it look like there's people in front and
behind you well when we first went to
that building there were two teams
shooting us excuse me excuse me F F F F
F er respects that you know that what
yeah
alright how's that there's your middle
left go try out this race get crazy get
real crazy don't know how to use her
ultimate which is like seven portal and
then go I can out point for two portals
well
this chick is there a server selection
now
I like that guy's aesthetics yeah I
agree
she's good he's actually got some cool
looking skins are you going on the ship
again I don't know kinda I kind of like
doing that
my mom charged I can I can request it
it's really far away
yeah we can you got to believe I'm just
kidding it's too far
so it's kind of neat is I could like
branch off like this
Chad BeeZee asks what are your biggest
negative so far that you see with the
game
I think the cosmetics I don't really
care for it but they got to make money
somehow Rob oh I don't care about yeah
that's fine I just don't really care for
it I don't really have any attachments
like that stuff ultimate acceleration
the sauce talked about earlier I can
speed up my ultimate I can eat that
that's a consumable yeah why did they
release this on Monday not Friday they
really want me to skip school today
well sorry big lefty we're doing this is
making a big play but not telling them
telling you guys where to go you just
come back down in the same oh yeah low
jet packs that's sick yeah Oh James a
shotgun I think I'm pretty sure it was
Rob yeah that's good I like it the spaz
what's javelin Gables
go on here whatever that other big lefty
shooting someone for sure okay sit down
oh [ __ ] oh crap oh we make a big play
just kidding
you have your old have unita I don't
know how that's gonna help you though
it's me it's me a boy Roberto sorry
annoying through the window this guy
with the shotgun that shotguns pretty
nasty
I think you use that earlier to kill
someone yeah didn't have [ __ ] jackasses
guess I'll get back in it that's the
thing about a better well games you just
get back into it no problem are you
gonna play this with me Eric uh sure
yeah I'll play it for a week and see how
I feel about it yeah I mean looks fun
for me it's more figuring out all the
guns I didn't play too much time fall to
as I've told you even though I know you
love that game and adore it so it
probably learning more about the guns
the weapons how they how they work I
think if I wanted a more casual owning
experience I was just playing for this
war
play this student time cuz I could just
feel like it's easier to like every time
I played a battle royale it's been
easier on console than PC obviously yeah
the alter
I know what that goes and I know the Evo
those are the two guns I use the most
that's all I know
introducing you a champion trust just
your eyes in your lose that's fair
supply ship over there
let's make a choice land here all right
let's go to the ship no let's go over
here instead decisions decisions
that's far
no cross-play JCP release date it's out
today can you all run ask maximu snow
are the service so far they've been fine
yeah right at least on PC like we
haven't had anything from a server-side
happen I think the closest thing to a
weird bug that we had if it was even a
bug is when we phased through the world
on a reef what we were getting revived
while on the ship and somehow we phased
through the ship and so that kind of
like booted us all the way down to the
ground instead of staying up on the ship
where a other teammate was dead which is
unfortunate for obvious reasons is this
a new game yes
epic mantas show its apex of Legends
it's a new battle royale game from the
makers of titanfall respawn
Entertainment's there are some
similarities but you know most of the
big ones that people are asking about
like mechs while running things like
that those do not exist in this game
there's a box here left is it only among
those things though no oh good call
no there anything in there Z Eva blue
stock is this what became of the Star
Wars game no I don't think so
well it's not on Steam Antonio it's only
on origin it's an EA game so you're
gonna find this on origin it's about 22
23 gigs I think ish on place are PC so
what do the rounds mean the rounds mean
the circle round so like the first
circle is the first round the second
circle is the second round so you know
obviously the circle gets smaller and
you know you have to move to a certain
area on the map otherwise you start
taking damage crazy processes so
basically another battle royale we're
starting to get too many of these yeah
you know it is interesting it you know
what else is funny this one came out
before battlefields night I think about
it yeah but yeah I I will say though the
reception to blackout was better than I
thought it would be I guess if that
makes sense
like I think more people played it and I
maybe anticipate or just like stuck with
it for a while so I could see this game
doing well as as well just because one
is free to play - I think there's a lot
of titanfall fans out there so even
though this isn't in the exact same vein
I'm sure they're gonna try it out play
and then also there's squads of three so
it's more squad based just classes so
you know has something's definitely
going for it that are slightly different
than your traditional battle rail I
guess that's fair might be Bob lose that
you know they're happy that's free but
they're disappointed that it doesn't
play more like titanfall a Rob did speak
to the devs briefly about that so in
terms of like wall running and things of
that nature
they said they tried it but it just kind
of felt I think you use the word messy a
little bit yeah like they wanted to
stress you know being with your team and
when they added wall running and
and every way it would like people
wouldn't be able to stick together that
well you would continually be like
getting separated and they didn't want
that to happen so for what is I mean
granted if you had a single-player mode
maybe you could probably do some cool
wall running mm-hmm but is the gun
gameplay like titanfall yeah definitely
absolutely
we missed this bud so what's uh this is
a Gibraltar yeah Oh he's got a shield
and you can call down an airstrike I'm
gonna try right now from downtown just
kidding
oh there on the that near that rock
there pretty far away
yeah they're down in that like called a
ravine I think Rick should be above
those guys hope they're chasing where
he's up here no it's to your right I
think at least there's one guy below
where rick rosz
nice got them they're definitely not
coming after that I think it scared your
teammates
can you like stop that beer
well that was cool though like how do
you how does like how do you countering
us that I guess he just had to be inside
if they had a Gibraltar he could have
thrown his own shield okay great uh you
play this cosplays no Luka I don't
believe so it is on Xbox one Brandon
music horses can better always doubt
already I think there's only gonna be a
handful left that'll kind of survive
curious how the reception will be with
this game and how long it lasts people
are gonna continue playing it etc but
yeah I don't think you'll see that many
more it'll be like the MOBA trend you
know at some point people realize
there's only a handful that people are
really gonna stick with and play with
and then they're kind of like alright
move on you're next and of which you
know you could argue better rails have
been kind of like the next thing is
their battle pass I don't know
rob is there any yes there is there was
a battle pass that's something we just
missed in the store or is it maybe just
not out yet it was there actually we'll
have to uh ok later later yeah we ain't
doing too bad infinite slide as long as
you're coming down a hill special moves
are on a cool-down question work yes so
he has a shield on his cue and then his
ultimate so yeah I figured what my
passion is everyone has a passive
ability I forget what his is always
double check in the legends screen later
that's kind of freaking me out actually
like there's someone there well I guess
that's the whole point
yeah are there Titans now what do you
get in the battle pass we'll have to
find out Riley um well uh we'll go get
that or check it out after this match
that's a very exact timeframe from um
Yuja I don't believe it's on the switch
how does a healing system work uh I
believe you have like shield and
medical pack cynical shield this is
going to be a battery that does more
than a cell here what'd you get what'd
you get what'd you get there's a med
pack a med pack I needed something that
dude well they left it cuz I don't think
it was on the shelf yeah can you change
it over Washington possibly we haven't
checked or messed with controls at all
how is it compared to bat geez can talk
how is it compared to blackout
I'd say I mean there's a lot here guys
so it's squad base there's no solo as it
stands right now there's it's more it's
class-based yeah so there's missing
abilities and stuff each legend does
different things you generally want to
have like one support at least you know
cuz they can help do healing things like
that let me see what else is kind of
different these sliding you can slide
for a pretty long while the weapons are
very reminiscent of titanfall also there
is the kind of like respawning like if
your teammate gets fully down if they
actually have the patience to wait it
out you can take their banner to a
respawn location which I think that was
just right like one of those deposits
yeah that was them right there back to
it and so you could bring them back that
way does it cost anything or is it just
literally bringing the banner they're
just bringing it you bring like you know
this especially the dog tag of your
fallen comrade and you can bring it back
yeah no vehicles huh right no vehicle
okay you can use these balloons in front
of you to kind of like traverse the map
you like I wouldn't say I guess it's
kinda like ziplining or climbing up yeah
and there are zip lines kind of fly back
down the ping system is pretty good it's
better than your like traditional one it
lets you kind of not only point out
other enemy targets it also lets you
relay other information like hey I have
a heavy ammo here if you need it or
other things like that what else do you
think I missed in that kind of
that's a lot Oh the the item some
certain items have more like perks to it
whereas like let's say for example one
of the armors he had was kind of like
when he executed some when he looked
fully recharged a shield so there are
things like that is there fall damage no
no fault of all damage which is
interesting
that's a tough battle to win there yeah
really well just see where this is there
you go
teamwork I like it he's telling him he's
pushing up that's interesting oh he's
out of the ring
yeah we didn't have to press that I know
why we did I'll go with him there were
people over there yeah they're probably
rotating over cuz circle collapse
I guess I'll ask this question 14 doctor
says how do you feel about the how do
you guys feel about the hype for a
titanfall game but instead we got
something more like a cookery fortnight
I'll kind of relay that question back to
Rob later they're pretty much in a top
almost like 12 situation I don't know
what this is how many four times three
yeah top twelve situation so well we'll
circle back to that 14 doctor I think
it's fair I mean yeah we'll talk about
it later
yeah I mean I I think I think I should
take their time with it and you know I
think as we are expecting new console
generation 2020 right hopefully I mean
let's just just they should save it
make it real good and keep this doesn't
add something to what you know to the
silver oh is he with guys okay he just
killed two
he's spying on me
oh he did kill that like a DMR whoo nice
grenades will that hit indoors I don't
know do something maybe
I was personally I didn't see that guy
three squads left I was like I just
toasted yep all right wait how is there
still three squads maybe some guy
revived how are you on the circle I
guess you must be in the circle or is
there a friendly fire um I don't believe
so it doesn't look like it right I don't
think there is yeah
is there a shooting range there was in
the training yeah
oh they spotted enemy okay okay you guys
are pretty close to the next circle
which is good
devotion just makes me nervous watching
you but I guess your teammates would
solution charging my shields how much
damage does the storm do I haven't
checked yet yeah they're telling Rob to
pushes out here in a second
tazer turtle part of it was because the
devs actually tried it with wall running
and just said that it felt like a
Messier experience people were kind of
like leaving knocked each other and like
yeah it just didn't feel good in their
perspective so that was ition they they
made and went with so yeah crime doesn't
ring up with a good point that the
shield popping up like that does look a
bit jarring but I'm sure once you get
used to it I deploy be fine so I'm
guessing your shield allows you to does
it allow you to shoot out of it or is it
just a like block stuff out my build my
ability I don't think I can shoot out of
there so it's good for like you know
reviving someone who's down yeah nice
okay ash Judah has clearly played
wraiths I think he's in the building
it's a big door
you guys are in the circle this is good
we're gonna have a little showdown
indoors it looks like unless the circle
ring
so yes Kade free on all platforms
you have a little uh Rick hello Rick
okay so you guys are near the circle
which is good okay
alt yes Steve it is public available on
PC through origin and then ps4 and Xbox
one as well look through it in the store
free-to-play right now find some shotgun
for close range dude he has a shotgun
the eva 8 is a shotgun there up there
how they got up there are they outside
[Music]
kill leader I think yeah he's kicking
ass ashen guy yeah
it's going in so on the hunt
two squads left I didn't do [ __ ] he said
let's go we did it we are the champions
champions cool I'm gonna try evening
playing again that felt really fun yeah
I think um I think anyone that's gonna
like judge or anything like that should
just play it I mean there's it's
literally free you can make your own
kind of like interpretation of if you
enjoy it or not so that's cool
what we want to do now you want to you
want sure what haven't you tried I guess
open a little little box a little spicy
boy to Hue right yeah I believed from
the beginning carried sometimes you get
put in backpack that's all right I live
to be put in a backpack I don't mind
don't worry all right they have voice
lines who can I try that leader is pro
yeah it's always like I think that's
what's gonna be interesting about this
battle royale is as you mentioned it's
more team-based it's definitely it's
definitely squad based obviously and I
think that communication is definitely
gonna help kind of can't wait to play
with you Rob actually no yeah a little
well sesh you know yeah apex Legends
sesh you want you want to play on PC or
ps4 I don't know you tell me I'll
probably play mostly ps4 I could play
either one
all right who should I be pick one play
huh
did you guys ask did you guys ask them
at all about trying to [ __ ] me or
anything like that
yeah they had Dave we're gonna answer
anything answers they're working on it
give more time
oh they're apparently a lot of Muse has
come out that there is no titanfall 3
rub what does that mean
attack vol 3 is not if it works I think
there's been at least two places I've
seen links to seeing that so okay let's
see apparently according to Eurogamer
who spoke with respawn producer drew
McCoy they drew McCoy told Eurogamer
that titanfall 3 wasn't happening but I
don't know I don't know if that's like
miss like I don't know if that's like
necessarily misinterpreted or missing I
could sounds like it's I don't know
that's just what I see so no ps+ for
apex legends on ps4 that is now
confirmed by PR and some of you folks
already said that and I appreciate that
so thank you so one of the few games
that that is free-to-play that you don't
need to have PS Plus which is awesome so
again check that out Oscar Rojas yeah
that was the article I was showing rob
just now about the titanfall 3 but that
originally was sourced from Eurogamer
which I also saw that one as well
Viper's so sick of VR well again you
don't have to play if you were
interested in battle Royales at all like
I had mentioned I would say maybe give
this a go it's free-to-play and I only
say that because there are some
differences but again if if you're sick
of them you know you definitely have to
play I think there's plenty of games out
there either out or coming out that will
you know fill a need for you that's the
beauty of video games I feel like
there's there's games for everyone so
yeah should have called this apex
champions
I don't know legend legend sounds cooler
than champions right like you are a
champion or you are a legend I think
legend sounds better like the legends
are the people that you remember no
matter what like even if they want one
championship oh if there's a
spot on spot to which our way to do that
I can use for okay so there is [ __ ] guys
shield up nice headshot yeah let's go is
there fall damage a sea turtle no sorry
Rob
you focus on slaying I will try to do
questions or some of your way you're
still fighting hop over this wall you're
gonna find some baddies
oh he's fighting too I might have been
that squad that they just finished off
there that slide that oh did you not get
it yeah you have cells how diverse is
the map hmm from what I've seen it's
okay
it's like a lot of building or open
areas that cave area was cool I'd have
to defer to Rob for that question what
was questioning it how diverse is the
map it's fairly diverse I guess there's
like different I don't know it's not
like I mean I'm diverse as far as biome
or like color like yeah there's like
there's like desert there's trees
there's there's a lot like of cool
things I guess
no Titans can you even wall run no I
don't believe there's leaning mechanics
right no lenient annex no looks like the
same weapons aside fall to there are how
big is the inventory I think your
backpack and get up to are always at 14
yeah 14 looks like the biggest backpack
you can get to any word on solimões no
not yet how is the inventory management
in general it seems okay like you saw it
there did you play on console at all I'm
just curious like how that compares in
PC because patient's pretty quick you
know yeah I didn't play on console
that's a good question
because that would be the more tricky of
the two I feel like because PC you're
pretty good like pretty easily can kind
of drag and drop stuff you know a lot of
hills to slide down it looked like there
were definitely some for sure oh yeah
how's it going pretty far you might want
can you reload right now does he
extended magnet nope got trollee is the
lever shotgun new I think that shotgun
that we saw and liked I think that is
new okay
and only because there's only really two
shotguns Rob
Wow seem like they're so far away
where's that dude oh you got like 10
stinks you spraying Rob he's fridge
there you go oh yes oh no yes no - yes
you might want to health up and stuff
that was those were big plays so I'm
talking about Rob he's warmed up now
ladies and gents I think my speed was
increased with that ultimate I forget
what it does check it later that's why
we check it later
oh you have shield that's good I guess
I'm all good for now well we should
check their stuff later
oh that's why you gots to be careful in
the air look booting and scooty got do
the shimmy Rob Zuma shimmy alternate
accelerant Phoenix kit oh that's so good
that's like the double
all right I think I swore I was bad oh
snap
we're can download this depends if
you're on Xbox one look in the store we
got it we gots to go oh well at least
you got to see how bad the health goes
here is this round one though so
shouldn't be bet that bad round ones not
really doing that much - to be honest I
have no idea how far the circle is
you're fine dude level one no problem
how many legends are there currently
there's eight definitely not shocked did
we see more I round one very manageable
knows that rocks not right now currently
yes Jason Bentley jr. it is I like it
you're like I'm not afraid no ghosts no
you're fine you're just gonna have to
heal once you get to the edge there but
you're pretty much there whoo this slide
helps oh we could holster your weapon to
run fast mm-hmm that's good all right
time to met up
yes it is elite gaming on all three
platforms PC on Origin ps4 Xbox one
it's a believe it's a full release right
it's not considered a beta no it is yeah
full game nailed it down shield no wall
jump Scott sell me some pie says
download me on PC right now looks
amazing for a free battle royale how do
I get on ps4 or search for it in the
store or like someone said like go to
like what's hot or something like that
and it's it's also there maybe not who
they're pretty far up can you heal and
run look like he was you can move I
don't think you know that you can sprint
no Chad bzz I don't think so we did the
we did the slide jump it pretty much
just kind of like slows your it doesn't
have the slide hop from what we can tell
and crime it basically you slide and
then like you jump and you stop it
doesn't
yeah like build momentum where whatever
this is a new shotgun peacekeeper it's
like one new weapon do you know if
they're gonna add more Maps I don't know
okay they haven't really said about that
figured I just asked and said lady
savoury says it is featured right now in
the PS door yeah like when I looked on
the PS Store it was like the first thing
I saw granny I kind of knew it was there
so do you need PlayStation Plus no Kyle
we've confirmed with even PR that whoa
damn it I will go get I will go get all
right
not good
I spilled coffee I wouldn't worry so
much about the in the keys we can always
flip it later
sorry he's cleaning off his keyboard cuz
he spilled coffee it's fine
worry about it later Rob there's only
six squads left whoops yeah just get
that out there
Mario love saying I say it looks good
for a free-to-play game
yeah I mean I can't wait to try it looks
like it plays pretty smooth as well I
need to see some shooting Oh we'll see
some shooting soon you missed it when he
got his three kills earlier he went
indoors with his Eva eight shot Ian and
did some work fouled out I'm not sure if
you need Xbox Live but since you don't
need PS Plus part of me feels like you
don't need it but I can't confirm or
deny that I guess I can ask for you
though Johnny can't can or con says yes
I can confirm do not need me please yeah
I got that confirmation earlier so but
thank you for confirming as well Krispy
ska it says I can't wait to download
you've spilled yeah yes Tyler it is is
this only squads or is there solo to
only squads right now I mean the way the
game is I think it's gonna continue to
be that way because I'm not even sure
how it will work solo with all the class
abilities but you never know we haven't
got any answer in terms of like what
modes are gonna come this is what's out
this is what's available so yeah check
it out
Oh Dragon Skin Melly Otis I think that
even though the pros from titanfall kind
of know the game I don't think they're
gonna necessarily be too Opie just
because it still plays differently from
them titanfall - and I think a lot of
the the good Battle Royale players in
general like I don't know like the
shrouds of the world will just be
equally or if not as good as the
titanfall two pros so yeah we're just
chilling here for a second cuz work
related work back in it to win it
there's kind of like a Mansell jump yeah
that's just a Phoenix kit I think you
have a purple already oh no this is an
ultimate boost no wait
yeah I think that that's why pick that
holds my acceleration whoo I'm looking
pretty good it's interesting that um
there actually isn't that many random
golds around though what do you mean by
like gold tier items yeah I haven't
really seen them and he has like
definitely on the ship we saw like a
handful right look but you mentioned
that that was a spot that there would be
more of but I haven't really seen you
know like a gold arm or a gold helmet
kind of thing like just out and about
but maybe we've been unlucky you know
you never know for sure they're
definitely rare you guys are gonna have
to get your move on which they're doing
yeah well we're going into the swamp the
swamp all right well we haven't been
here that's cool
here's some hearing some fighting what's
that that's like a in-game care package
there because there fall damage no this
is the PC version yes Mario so you
definitely don't want that
good stuff here
okay weird you guys are sitting pretty
in the circle on some of those Crocs in
the river
apex already mm-hmm
oh there's a drop let's team over there
oh my god these guys are far yep they're
not even in the circle is the thing I
might just stay here well yeah I mean
you should be fine until you have to
potentially move up and that's the issue
but there is no backup
oh they slid down or jump down your
teammates that is mm-hmm no friendly
fire baby boy from what we've seen call
me lecture please don't spam that in our
chat thank you right how much does this
storm do for us round one seems pretty
miniscule like you could get out of it
run through it if you had to and he'll
not sure about like round two and uh
three and four etc I'm sure it's like
many other battle rails where it gets
progressively worse and probably like
gonna kill you is there free for a
limited time or forever I think it's
forever joy Roy it's just out and about
for you to play if you want to can i
plug keyboard mouse into a Playstation 4
and be playing a keyboard maybe I don't
know like you could per fortnight right
so I don't see why not but I haven't
tried it so I would know for sure
let me see if I can get the the specs
for you that you may or may not need all
right PC specs says minimum Intel Core
i3 6300 or an AMD FX 4356 gigs of ram a
g4 640 ok so you can run this pretty
easily cheap yeah 30 gigs of free space
just in case recommended is i5 8 gigs
RAM GTX 970 so yeah it sounds like it'll
pretty much play on most pcs unless you
have like an 8 to 10 year old PC but
yeah
what's going in huh three squads left
how does EA make money off this game
well there is still like
microtransactions in the sense that
there's a lot of cosmetics that you can
get skins and a bunch of other stuff so
you know you could buy those coins if
you want to buy the different skins by
the gun skins different things like that
I think you guys are in a crappy spot I
mean this this it's gonna be a crappy
spot no matter what I know but like I
just feel like you're in the open you
have nowhere to run basically but it's
gonna come down to I'm gonna jump on
this though and go straight out to come
back down oh that's a very important
anything to do but you also expose
yourself by doing that right uh oh he
did he's very dead does their shotguns
Rob's gonna go in maybe it's only one
squad left she's good Oh keys you sense
of where they're at that's pretty cool
actually okay so this his ultimate
basically gives you like animal
instincts or sense of oh he's really but
he's reviving our guy through the Moose
down yeah nice a shield again oh they're
getting shot now though okay the guys
respawning which is awesome they are
shooting from far away I feel like I
think you can chill though Rob cuz
they're gonna have to push see you in 25
seconds and I want that because I have a
shotgun yes sir oh is that his ability
his ability can see footprints and where
people were oh oh they're new you rob
that's totally right out there he's
coming around to you yeah it's right
there yeah buddy
one of your teammates is down your than
you kill leader let's go to second so
you can ping again
Oh No
let's go even his teammate was fired up
better the ham where the shooter shooter
and he was killed later and we probably
should have recorded that but it doesn't
matter cuz you guys all saw it
dude that seems really good his
abilities though yeah yeah for sure
first game you know it's my first game
you know I will say that's that's the
one thing that is cool about be ours or
battle Royales is if you do win you do
get that like exhilarating sense that
like just as we did right there
so yeah that's fun to kill someone
outside the circle you know just like
good [ __ ] let's go for it well you
know it's funny I was watching just to
see how bad it was melting your health
and I was gonna be it's time to run but
you know I think if you in that
situation your other teammate was still
alive
I believe so if as long as you killed
him it didn't really matter right for
sure or he would have died too the
circle probably ooh look at that epic
epic banner pose that could have been
you on the banners Shh I like him
no I mean like his abilities seem really
good and he's the only character or like
legend of that that clasp type-r I like
it like recon scout right right like
he's very much a tactical player right
well yeah but it helps your team or like
in ways if you were the shot-caller you
could be like hey there to our left at
the houses because you could see them
right shooting like that even when
they're when they weren't even shooting
you could see their like icons
come on and then you got that easy kill
with the ping ability because you're
just like always right these are crazy
right right
Oh someone's to check the battle pass
right
sorry warrior can we get down so we know
we check it after why don't you get
'spicy that's that's what we used to do
what what we used to say I mean
Nicholas margarita we just go into the
really spicy areas and just fight are
the skins free I mean you earn them
through the game for free if you want to
for whatever reason get those skins
sooner you can pay for them you can buy
them all the skins are cosmetic of
course I'll be a team player
alright lifeline oh we're going double
support here that's fine oh you're right
it's fine it's okay
it's hi how many people start the game
60 20 squads of three we will check out
the battle paths I apologize I will I
wish I had to post a note to just slap
on my monitor have you talked about
wraiths we played wraiths really briefly
I don't think Rob played too much
wraiths so it's hard to tell you much
about oh yes do it so we're we are gonna
go to that ship because Oh solo and
that's where you get good items how come
I accidentally gave the command to go to
someone else those my bad
alright well if you want to try to fight
for good items you land on that ship
that ship has from what we did last time
at least two like gold items or
legendary items on there but you know
obviously it's probably a more spicy
area so you know you're probably
fighting for that stuff I would say the
other thing is even mentioned earlier
that I forgot to say again is the time
to kill definitely feels a little longer
yeah especially given like the armor and
all that stuff so that's kind of cool
yeah yeah it feels different
that's the the Peacekeeper I'll try this
out seems so you seems like a good it
seems like a good combo here the eva
really was good for you though last
round yeah I like the Eva I think that
got like 4 kills or something I really
know that gun
how big is the map when compared to
other battle royale games it's kind of
small
okay III think so at least not like by a
margin nor is it a bad thing it feels I
don't know maybe not it I don't feel
like it's as big as blackout or Deaton
is smaller than blackout I think it's
smaller I think it's there are there are
many there's less people yeah and there
aren't it doesn't feel it by any means
bad and there it just feels like there
aren't many any like huge open areas you
know I mean oh I'm gonna go for it yeah
they're going for it too curious if he
even meant to hit you up there's another
guy because big Rob
around [ __ ] that was dumb is
unfortunately a guide to your block the
other way okay
Oh your dude you're so exposed other
robot on friend I know he really is
that's fine you can use your drones well
you're right that's okay
you had a scent of blood what sort of
movement options are there I mean it's
mainly uh as you see the slide is
probably the biggest kind of like
movement thing if you can get down a
hill you can really get some speed but
yeah do you think the screen is
cluttered with stuff oh not really
but again I haven't I haven't played yet
I'm just going based off of watching Rob
but I don't I think it's pretty standard
we lost rather dude I think he just left
he didn't even bother waiting for this
that's the only thing I can see as
another kind of maybe shortcoming but
again I would probably do it too which
is kind of bad is that you can be
respond even if you get down as long as
your teammates get a banner you take
your banner to a respawn location but I
feel like most people because they're so
used to the idea of battle royale yeah
mentality also because they might not
just know that either right you're
probably jumping in the game and
thinking like oh I'm down I'm dead like
I'm not just gonna sit here and watch my
teammates but there is a way to come
back which is what we saw a last game
actually the person was like downed but
then he went and grabbed the banner and
was able to respawn him which helped
potentially Rob's team went out the
match there what do you think is a good
meta like shotgun in a are I think
pens it's hard it's day one I don't even
know if you can speak to a meta just yet
shotguns definitely very useful in close
quarters though there's a lot of close
quarters though - oh is there why I just
feel like it like again like I feel like
they're like compared to other battle
Royales like you're there's some sniping
but there's just a lot of it feels like
close quarters and like hallways and
interiors
daelin we haven't had trouble connecting
but we're on PC not sure if you're on a
different platform controls hard the
controllers ask Mario they're gray it's
very fluid it feels really good I mean
it you know yes there's no wall running
but like all the other aspects of Tydfil
I feel like we're here um slide is good
play solo or is it only teams with you
currently Christian only teams of three
so no solo right now not sure like not
sure what other modes and things they're
gonna do yet it's too early to tell but
if you want to try this out it's out
free a model on PC via Origin ps4 Xbox
one pull this a lot of our same guys
asking will just be better than
fortnight I think it's way too early to
tell I think it's different I think it's
going to be very hard for any other
battle royale game to really like take
like take away from fortnight there's
just so many people that play forward
night
I just don't know oh there's a guy
climbing the rope
he's shooting them you're right oh
you're gonna drop down on him dare you
rob big plays he's shooting me you know
he's shooting that guy
different levels of armour a question
mark yes anywhere from the basic to blue
to purple to gold the gold ones is it
just the gold ones that have perks or
can yeah just legendary alright so the
legendary ones can have perks one
example is if you execute someone with
that legendary armor on you will then
regain full shield off the execution so
are you happy with the monetization I
mean it's a free to play game and as
long as they continue to only give
aesthetics with the like coins or
whatever and the money that you're
spending then I think it's totally fine
I don't really care because I'm never
gonna buy that stuff
let's do this are you guys in the bubble
not yet okay all right so this is a
level one round or round one closing so
you can see how much damage is doing to
Rob it's not too bad
again these balloons that Rob just
climbed up to is a way to kind of like
get through the map faster I still like
that rocket like a jetpack animation
what a bit he's running a different
route
I feel like
no he's that way it's fine I was like
where are you going I was oh I got
turned around looking the mini-map
standby for care package not titanfall
warrior
thanks for us appreciate the kind words
and thanks for stopping by
do you think they'll add Titans in
future game modes I think they could add
Titans to this maybe they will what you
think so a baby like me probably not
probably on either has to be like a full
Titan mode type thing or like nothing at
all I feel like what yeah car I can't
say your first name fortunately so
Carlos Correa yes it is live on ps4 Oh
so look at those banners real quick was
that just you that's interesting where's
the person that's number one
oh it's just you huh yes it says your
neighbor Rob no bacon you do not and I
am I'm surprised though at the fact that
there's been so many people that
actually have been using the voice comms
which is yeah pretty cool sure and they
haven't been like like total house Turks
or d-bags or you know
there have been people here robbed
exactly do the chest does the blue
highlight have any and okay for some
reason I thought it was maybe okay it
does indicate rarity yeah there yeah
it's it's telling us that there's some
good [ __ ] here some purples yeah
extended mag I'll take that I'll take
that yeah you need some better armor and
a helmet though for sure yeah oh no you
have a purple omelet
its armor that you're lacking in maybe
you should give that guy shield cells
later feel like oh no maybe you don't
have any to spare backpack Oh thermite
grenade huh like that's like a that's a
kind of flashbang I think that's what
I'm thinking of yes Michael it is out
herpes what is the glad you're having
fun with it sir games ouch the wall
flame nevermind I'll take that place it
was one minute robbed uh Higashi cut the
I would just try it out yourself it's
pretty readily Avera available so I
would just give it a go you know it's
not better I have that how far is the
circle Rob you gotta go oh my god
why do you keep putting it I don't know
I spelled again like I can't see it with
the mic there or something
well no I have the mic I blame the mic I
believe we know setup what I've learned
is you never put a drink in between like
me and my board hand and your mouth and
because I have spilled multiply multiple
times the same way yeah unfortunately
but I also I guess it's my fault because
the setup the way it is is kind of like
oh he did this he said he's got his
special is the zip line oh really
yeah so he just set that up that's cool
there's not really a great space for you
to put the coffee I suppose because it's
pretty far from where you're at but
whatever well let's download sighs this
game I think it was 22 to 23 gigs on PC
so I was saying 17 for ps4 and then like
maybe a little bit more for Xbox but
yeah
more coffee droppage yes yes very much
so
upon this I don't know oh it it's teknon
as I say it is part of the thing but
it's not it's not part of the Ring
unfortunately nice work is that
someone's sensor tower no I don't think
anyone has needed gamespot cup holder I
don't know how do you cup holder a table
I guess I could put a couple there to
the left of him
Brian playing very day one better or
else tell hide in the corner I didn't
hide them no I said the guy your
teammate he was crouched in that corner
maybe just wanted to put that up
explore the care package do the controls
move clean it seems like it I haven't
played it yet though but earnest Robb
felt pretty good about it earlier I
think controls wise mm-hmm no Chester
there is not you hmm
if you get some slide and then a jump
you can get it you can get a little a
little like finesse there that would be
me no is that subbu net you cannot
you saw one he saw something
[Music]
like all that you know I mean like that
feels so natural like it's it's it's a
really good system can you invite your
friends into a squad or is it already
teammates I mean we haven't tried by I
would believe you could yeah I don't see
why not
is definitely a team based game and you
need some new armor you're good on ammo
Rob trust me yeah yeah nothing but ammo
right now are the matches quick they can
be DCC I think it depends where you drop
how frequently you're running into other
folks how much you're just wanting to
loot things like that we've had some
pretty fast games especially when you go
to try to land on the ship right away
because there's definitely good loot
there
just let him have the shield battery I
want it
well he's got to shield that he's off of
right now at least drop him a cell Rob
you have six bottom left yeah can you
divide that up I don't know yeah you can
did he need it he's are you looking at
his armor oh you're right that's what I
was trying to tell you this whole time
like he's at two out of four armor yeah
but he only has a level one armor no he
has purple armor no he doesn't he has he
is is the purple above his name not
purple armor oh I'm looking at me I'm so
dumb yes okay take the other one
whatever you guys gotta go I think oh no
you're good you guys are good because
you're in the circle yes it is high
ruler origin check the origin store or
origin I don't know I call it a store I
guess in some ways it is technically a
story that was a goddamn gun
it's zipline time house it time to kill
it's actually longer oh yes I need that
eating that oh this guy's not using his
shield cells whatever you can only do so
much to help I guess this place there's
a lot of armor who the circles no that's
close oh is it okay you can see how
quickly we can get there
hmm yeah purple
all right I feel like you guys have gone
the pacifist route you might still win
because there's only two squads left so
it's you and the other squad yeah I
didn't even notice yeah
the question is do they have all three
of their their team or not
is this a lot of dots titanfall battle
royale I mean it's made by the same
developers as titanfall and there's some
similarities but no it's just Apex
legends it's a battle royale made by
Respawn Entertainment circle closes no
Charlie there is not Hector asking
what's different about this battle
royale why should I play this instead of
blackout or realm rail okay first of all
currently no solos it's a squad of three
it's class-based so there are supports
there was like a recon type character
there's like kind of like a defender so
that's one time to kill is kind of a
little longer than your traditional
battle royale I feel like what else oh
I'm trying to think I had so many
earlier it's got titanfall to ask guns
look at me it's got every guns from time
faulty yeah it also has a the ability
for you to bring back a fallen comrade
one that has been like technically
eliminated you can technically take
their banner to a respawn point and then
bring them back to life
which is pretty cool except right now
when you when you kind of match up with
randoms you probably tend to just leave
the game but it is in the game so
there's a way back I guess yeah we
haven't seen anyone else right now we if
you watched our last match we had about
five or six kills and we won the whole
thing this is how bad or else go
sometimes though you kind of get through
the map you don't really see anyone and
now it's up to us and Bryan SPG to see
if we can where are they they're behind
us I feel like you think so
like over here we're about to find out I
mean the circle is gonna get smaller
here so
we'll see the hope is that there's only
two of them as well and not a they don't
have a full stack but you never know I
guess
don't forget to use like your cue later
like right now you guys are in a good
position in terms of like if they're far
away but it could be up there well
they're gonna have to move out of that
house if that's the case this is us this
is part of what happens on the first day
and you know you're like one of the last
two squads left over there there there's
two of them there's two there's one pass
- yeah he sees him Snipes
what that was weird like broke his
shield oh it was you doing it - that
much yeah he's going on here you didn't
get how they smoked
[Music]
they're running Oh watch out no [ __ ] oh
it actually tells you that it's close to
hitting you
you literally put one on they like the
ground part I hope he doesn't get
flanked right now on the other side okay
dead alright pretty
oh this is not good not good
they'll never see you and there's some
holy screw that up
oh that guy had 11 kills I told you that
out smoke aru's well it was close you
win some you lose some
I couldn't tell if there was three of
them or not there's up to yeah alright
let's look at a battle pass I thought
there was a battle past maybe that comes
later
I guess I'm wrong I thought um another
was I thought they say men it doesn't
require pliat ps+ does they have
microtransactions yes but they're only
cosmetic so at least for now oh you got
a goal they did great crafting with you
bunch of crafting material Oh 600 what
is that by yeah yeah it's a lot um
it lets me it's like one of the ways you
can unlock [ __ ] so I can't unlock okay
so Phil's preview said that there will
be about yeah there will be I'm pretty
sure there will be there's no
confirmation that's live so let's see I
like the Eva you're gonna use it on a
gun what else should I use it on I don't
know like a legends skin or something
why would I use this is so close to
anthem I don't think well that's a good
question actually I was gonna say I
don't think that many people that are
gonna be playing this will tighten that
technically play anthem but maybe this
is the PvP that you can get that you
won't get an anthem because there's no
PvP anthem so you know that's actually a
decent logic there you do whatever you
want Rob what do you want to do now
let's just play again all right Rob's
back in it I have not eaten lunch but
you know what it doesn't matter do you
want to do one more no no we're going
yeah this is this I think this next one
is the last one we'll do one more match
one hot match thank you everyone for
tuning in we appreciate it
we were checking out apex legends which
is now out free-to-play PC on Origin or
via origins ps4 Xbox one don't need PS
plus I didn't get full confirmation on
Xbox Live so sorry about that
but yeah thanks for tuning in guess what
life we were normally live Monday to
Friday 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
if you haven't subbed we should so you
get notification of when we go live but
also when we do cool videos on you know
big games coming out games that just get
announced like apex legends today
impressions will be going I think
impressions might be up from you right
yeah definitely so you can check that
out after a stream if you want Robb
chatting with the Aaron just about his
full thoughts it's yeah bloodhounds a
cool character I think I would play that
character just because he in some ways
reminds me a blood-borne I don't know
why oh I don't think that anthem
necessarily needs PvP life destiny I
just think that or I was just making the
point that this game will give you that
PvP flavor because someone asked why
this during okay close to anthem yeah so
this is gonna be our last match go try
it if you want alright jhh second or
third games time to be a winner are we
are the jump masters and we are gonna go
after that ship because there is good
loot now we're going to the ship we're
going to the ship
yeah that's ready uh-oh does that team
gonna get there sooner than you I think
they are ooh this is not gonna be good
oh there they're passing it they said no
sir all right
there's already a gold armor right
behind Rob oh there's another team Rob
kind of stuttery oh come on yes sorry
you were like swagging on him so hard
that I was like you gotta get this guy
oh that's that purple things good right
that's gonna give you shield and armor I
think I'm gonna have to get Rob used to
using for yeah Jesus Garcia I would try
it yourself and kind of like decide on
your own but if you're into battle rails
if you enjoy titanfall I think
definitely worth checking out
good thing for no fall damage alright
confirmed twice now if you get revived
in the ship no I just find unused new
spot this one's been a little bit huh
it's been stuttery this one this match
for some reason yeah we just played
through it roll through the punches or
with the punches yeah with that was a
nice slide one that was very tight and
volley right there right well slide into
mm-hmm
SMG alternator life seems something meet
up with her and we I think I'm gonna
pull that little sound bite as like one
of our just another one of the Eric and
Rob stream scenarios no I don't want
that
I like how our healer is hella far away
but that's just because we got that sick
revive on the ship feature where you
just kind of let them have this that gun
right do you need body armor so bad
Europe up jackpot um and your buddy
that's far away is fighting some folks
sadly oh yeah I guess I do
what's the other gun that you have us
all right yeah sorry I'm not versed in
the title it's okay you'll learn yes you
uh what are you streaming tomorrow at
SDCC that is a good question I don't
know if I planned out tomorrow yet to be
honest you have to find out you have to
stop by to find out 11:00 a.m. he's
still alive
yeah maybe I'll ask to rob just reading
this again I don't know we'll see or
your thoughts on that Rob I'm game drop
on what a syringe you have a syringe
you're such a liar
nah just giving it miss kidding I do
oh dude syringe does like that so
syringe is like a bandage hey we found
him there you go healer no come back
oh you guys are good thank you
well you guys are streaming the DMC 5
demo is that what is that is that
tomorrow I feel like it was at March
right you see five if it's tomorrow
we're definitely do that I'm gonna have
to find out oh yeah I'm gonna have to
find out last one was like in December
anything I'd like a stream of coffee
spawning no that's horrible
I already happened twice
that so that would have been the respawn
area if you had the team banner and they
were just like down right right there
yeah it's on the seventh ah good to know
oh we're probably going to do you can
always use your alt to find those folks
too but we'll probably doing something
else on the 7th potentially we'll see
you see imagine a doom battle royale
isn't that quake champions so now we're
just kidding it that's more of like a
it's not about a real I'm sorry
good lord give me inside come on come
back inside take the health back oh
they're good Michael Cabral is asking is
it good I mean if you enjoy battle
royale if you enjoy titanfall I just say
check it out
you know it's free no skin off your back
to just try it
did you get them nope
nice let's finish him off oh oh you're
in such a weird spot
smoked up here
these are cute later
nice frisky
room I come I come I come I come I come
I come I come come on come on okay
hopefully the smoke oh don't do it kill
the guy
don't do it kill the guy got him nice
city yeah yeah cuz he eliminated yeah
yeah so this whole team killed the other
guy I down the other guy yeah yeah yeah
oh so get the banner later show that
show that hot and then there's a thing
right behind you too
sorry on the map technically I'll
recover the banner no is he gone for it
oh is he not it says respawn time out
cuz you guys didn't pick up his banner I
thought you couldn't leap ick up his
bail rip in pepperonis robbed rip Tiger
midnight it was good knowing you I have
no body shield executioner okay so
that's the shield that or that's the
armor that lets you get your full shield
if you do an execution so is there no
way to bring that person back you know I
just don't know Eric
we'll find out oh the guy left game so
it does have a limited timer so it's not
okay that's good to know
I've lost espanol no sorry
why check that purple winner in front of
you I don't think you did yet
for real like the game is really
entertaining says Nobu cha didn't
thinking I mean I think it's I'm curious
as well I haven't played it yet but I am
curious for sure big rod ATL no it's not
just PC it's on both consoles as well
all right now all we need is a better
helmet it looks like in the circle which
is good let's get up on this on this
roof now that what's that blue thing
you have to close around your guns huh
kind of I got our salt rifle in a little
perv SMG come on helmet or something oh
there was plenty of scope no and we show
this is anyone else having a problem
getting on not that I know it's two
portals I agree there it is I agree I
agree I think like this guy right into
the middle of the circle is this class
place at all very much so Leon you have
a better barrel
don't forget your ability stuff later
not now these use the exact same weapon
no type that's interesting that that
only has 18 bullets oh you got it
that's I would that slide was lit yeah
you can slide pretty far down if like
you're on a hill she's pretty cool oh
you had the footsteps huh
you can scent the scent what's that boy
someone's been here you can always use
your cutie to find out no hostels that
seems pretty strong but I guess it is a
30-second thingy
care package o1 front of you he's going
down the hill doing a big slide see you
always on me
[ __ ] oh where are you all coming from
Wow really put ourselves in the middle
huh
I mean you did I mean that's my men
you're you're here with me well you win
some you lose some
in that case we lost them you get a
package that's open on this apex power
all right
well well thanks everyone for tuning in
that was apex legend sits out today PC
ps4 Xbox well go check it out on PC its
origins of course as it's an EA game
leave that ok just though we have no
outro stuff anyways no worries
thanks again Rob for playing yep any
thoughts you want to part the stream
with others right yon its it feels good
it's a it feels good uh you know it's
free-to-play give it a shot give it a
whirl if you uh you know ours in you
know so inclined to have another battle
royale type game to play you know even
if you are hesitant if you don't like
Battle Royale I think this is this is
pretty fun I think I think even if you
you know find that genre questionable or
you know you don't really think it's too
high I think you should still maybe give
it a shot I don't know it's free-to-play
right yeah and I mean it's not
necessarily just like your traditional
better well there's no solo mode
currently you have to its a squad based
battle royale there's classes as well
but yeah as Rob mentioned it's free so
you know you can make your own decision
in terms of you know if you like it or
if you don't or if you just don't like
battle Royales in general obviously
you're probably not gonna play it but
you know at least you can try if you
want to come back tomorrow for years
right live 11 a.m.
we'll be back well I'll probably be back
I don't know about you depends on what
we play if we play this game again maybe
we'll see but we appreciate you guys all
hanging out if you haven't subbed you
should and if you want more further
impressions Rob has some up on case
watch calm also on youtube so check that
out but till next time thanks so much
Rob yeah thank you
you